[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a japanese science fiction film
called terraformars
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
far in the future overpopulation is
about to destroy the planet earth to
create a backup plan in case our
ecosystem fails humans decide to change
the atmosphere of mars and make it
suitable for human existence the process
is called terraforming they start by
growing a simpler form of life like moss
on its surface the moss would help to
increase the temperature of the planet
and make it similar to the earth's
temperature to spread moss over its
surface genetically engineered
cockroaches are sent i hope you're
taking notes elon musk
it is now the year 2597 somewhere in
tokyo two criminals named komachi and
nanao are being chased by the police
they run frantically through the crowd
but are caught as the police surround
them a futuristic vehicle levitates in
the sky and lands nearby
inside the vehicle is dr honda and his
assistant they're there to fetch the two
criminals and use them for their own
benefit the doctor offers them to be
part of the mars colonization mission
komachi and nanao will have to go to its
surface and eradicate all the cockroach
colonies since they are no longer needed
dr honda promises to pardon their crimes
if they agree to participate the duo
accepts the offer
cut to two years later nanao and komachi
are now trained and are flying to mars
with other criminals like them in a
spaceship called bugs ii
nanao is always skeptical of their
competence because the team is made up
of thugs and criminals as she is talking
to komachi about the matter the ship's
captain kesuki dojima informs them that
the ship is about to land on mars
surface he orders everyone to prepare
for landing after they finally touch
down on the planet they see that mars is
no longer red like it used to be rather
it looks more like earth spread with
green moss
lieutenant mina launches a device that
secretes chemicals into the air to kill
the cockroaches the captain then orders
them to spread around in a group of two
and see if the eradication process is
working they plan to meet in three hours
and choose their team members a team
member named asuka is paired up with
yakuza but she strangely insists on
being with the group's computer
specialist ichiro the captain accepts
the request not wanting a conflict to
arise the team's drones then locate
another ship sent 10 years ago called
the bugs one nearby dojima contacts the
doctor and tells him they are ready for
the first contact the doctor starts to
jump excitedly anticipating the results
of the mission the groups then step on
the surface and start searching for dead
cockroaches the two members named jen
and maria are confused to see no
cockroaches on the moss as they continue
looking suddenly the two come across
three strange creatures standing right
in front of them they quickly hide
behind a rock in fear they had not been
told about such large creatures who look
like human-sized anthropomorphic
cockroaches and have clubs as weapons
meanwhile komachi and nanao who are also
looking for dead cockroaches come across
the same creature komachi is fascinated
and tries waving at it but within
seconds the creature attacks nanao and
snaps her neck it then runs away in a
flash leaving nanao's limp body on the
ground nanao dies in komachi's arms and
he watches her in distress just then
jen's team arrives and tells komachi
about their encounter the creatures have
also killed asuka they rush back to the
ship and tell the captain about the
creature only to find out that the
captain knew about them from the very
beginning he was ordered not to tell the
team members about the creature by the
doctor the captain explains that the
cockroaches that were sent 500 years ago
evolved at a rapid speed because of the
abundance of radiation and now have
turned into creatures stronger than
humans now the doctor appears as a
hologram in front of the team and
assures them that they have nothing to
worry about the doctor had been
preparing for this very moment for a
long time he has prepared distinguished
injections for every member that will
grant them the superpowers of several
insects the drug will enhance their dna
by combining it with that of the insect
using those unique powers they can
battle the evolved cockroaches however
the members do not want to fight the
cockroaches rather they want to abort
the mission and fly back to the earth
immediately but soon their ship is
surrounded by the creatures one brave
team member named god lee volunteers to
divert the cockroaches until the others
restart the craft he heads outside and
injects himself with the chemical that
the doctor had provided as soon as he
does that a rapid mutation starts inside
his body turning him into a hybrid
between human and ground beetles now lee
is able to shoot out flames from his
body as beetles do with his new powers
lee battles the cockroaches who seem to
be as powerful as him he uses his unique
power and shoots fire from his hand the
force from the flames pushes the
creatures back and burns them but when
it subsides it is seen that only the
exoskeleton of the creature is burned a
cockroach then runs towards him and
kills him in a flash meanwhile another
cockroach latches itself to the
spaceship and breaks its windows it
enters the craft and immediately kills
two of the members the captain quickly
injects himself with the drug and starts
to evolve his dna is mixed with the dna
of bullet ants who have the ability to
carry things that are 100 times their
weight the captain then easily smashes
the cockroach to the floor and kills it
the team celebrates but their happiness
is cut short when they notice a crowd of
cockroaches heading towards the ship on
the radar knowing that they cannot
battle them all everyone decides to take
off and go back to earth however when
the lieutenant tries to start the ship
the engines malfunction and the system
shuts down it seems as though someone
has deliberately sabotaged the ship to
stop it from taking off the captain
quickly thinks of a plan he wants the
team to go to the bugs one and bring all
the necessary parts they will need to
fix bugs too while he fights the
cockroaches everyone agrees but ichiro
asks to stay behind with the captain and
help him before making his way to the
other ship komachi goes to see nanao's
corpse for the first time he notices
weird strings coming out of her mouth
but doesn't think much of it now the
team gets inside the mars rover which
will have to travel through a horde of
cockroaches a member named tezuka offers
to help them avoid the creatures and
injects himself with the drug he evolves
into immaculae bug who can shoot out
projectiles of gases in the form of
flame at a very high speed he uses his
power to propel the mars rover forward
through the crowd of cockroaches
meanwhile the captain fights the
cockroaches inside the ship with all of
his might but more and more of them keep
entering he quickly makes his way to the
control room and vacuums out the oxygen
inside the ship so all the cockroaches
inside would die due to suffocation his
plan works and soon the cockroaches
start to fall unconscious but the lack
of oxygen harms the captain as well
making both him and ichiro fall to the
ground at the same time the team inside
the rover sees something massive
approaching them when they get a clear
look they are surprised to see a massive
wave of millions of cockroaches coming
their way tezuka still doesn't back down
and uses all his power to propel the
ship forward they strike the creatures
and soon land safely on the other side
of the cockroach wave the group then
happily moves forward but not long after
another wave approaches them this one is
even larger than the first wave
containing millions of creatures tezuka
cannot handle them together so two of
the team members named maria and osaku
transform themselves into their hybrid
versions as well the three try their
best to fight off all the creatures but
the rover flips and aggressively lands
on the ground the three are thrown to
the ground while the ones inside the
rover are knocked out the rover turns
out to be on autopilot mode and takes
the members to the destination ship
kezuka maria and osaku try fighting the
horde of creatures but are eventually
killed when the group inside the rover
gains their consciousness back they are
already at bugs one they make their way
inside while two members guard the
entrance mina tries to run a diagnostic
of the ship and they soon realize that
the ship is transmitting data to someone
on earth just then the group hears
gunshots and rushes outside both of the
guards have been killed the cockroaches
have found the weapons in the bugs one
and are using them to fight komachi
injects himself with the drug and
mutates into a massive hornet with his
newfound powers he can punch holes
through the cockroach's bodies and kill
them in one go jen does the same and
turns into a desert locust that can jump
up to 90 stories high while mina
transforms into a praying mantis that
can slash the cockroaches into pieces
the team battles the cockroaches and
kills them in no time the scene changes
to the doctor calling someone the phone
is picked up by one of the cockroaches
on mars unlike the other cockroaches it
can speak japanese and communicate with
the doctor he warns the insect not to
get close to kamachi once he transforms
because his insect is extremely
dangerous after ending the call the
cockroach goes inside the ship bugs too
and re-circulates its oxygen then the
creature's body tears down the middle
and out emerges a transformed asuka from
inside the team had thought she was dead
but it turns out that she was on the
doctor's side the whole time her unique
power after being injected is that she
has the ability to control the
cockroach's minds just like an emerald
cockroach wasp so she manipulated the
insects to go against each other and
survived she then kills the captain and
pours water into ichiro's body ichiro
too has been in on the plan since the
beginning his body has transformed into
the asian coronavirus uh coronamide a
creature who can survive in extreme
conditions and only needs water to
reactivate the doctor has assigned them
on a mission to bring a cockroach egg
back on earth so the japanese government
can breed them and use them to
strengthen their military this was their
prime mission and the cockroach
eliminating mission was just a decoy
ichiro and asuka then take off the ship
with the egg in it however the egg
starts to hatch midway and gives birth
to two evolved cockroaches asuka tries
to use her power to control them but it
doesn't work the creatures are far more
evolved from the others making them the
most powerful ones of them all they kill
asuka and call their own kind for help
the cockroaches on the surface hear the
call and flap their wings to fly to the
ship when a swarm of cockroaches latches
onto the ship it starts to malfunction
and crash beside bugs one the evolved
cockroaches come out of the ship and
order the others to attack kamachi and
the group komachi injects himself with
the other dose of the drug speeding his
evolution they do not have much
difficulty fighting the normal
cockroaches but the evolved ones are
hard to defeat one of them kills mina
after ripping her arm off jyn injects
himself with the second dose of the drug
while kamachi is on his third dose with
their heightened powers they kill more
cockroaches rapidly however the
creatures are nowhere near backing down
jyn injects himself yet again and
develops a pair of wings now the
cockroaches fly in the sky and battle
him they attack the two in waves and do
not die down because of their number
eventually jen realizes that to defeat
them they should defeat the evolved
leaders he injects himself multiple
times with the drug speeding his
transformation and making it
irreversible with every dose after that
he kicks one of the leaders and knocks
his head off with immense power but now
he has used all his powers and cannot
fight anymore komachi tries defending
jinn from the other leader but is
defeated easily before the leader can
kill them a magical glowing creature
comes flying towards them it spreads
glowing dust all around as everyone
looks at it in awe the flying creature
is nanao who has evolved into her final
form komachi flies towards nanao but
before he can get her one of the
cockroaches fires at him however the
dust nanao has spread turns out to be
tiny explosives that cause a chain of
explosions taking all the cockroaches
with them jen flies away before the
explosion can get him and saves komachi
just in time however nanao dies in the
explosion sometime later komachi wakes
up and sees jen has completely turned
into an insect jin asks kamachi to go to
earth without him as this is his new
life now kamachi obliges and makes his
way to the ship before he can reach
inside he sees that the leader is still
alive he punches the weak cockroach but
spares his life out of kindness inside
the ship he finds ichiro still alive
ichiro saves komachi's life by shooting
the cockroach behind him the two then
finally launch the escape pod and fly
away to earth as the cockroaches watch
them back on earth the doctor notices
that ichiro has hacked into their system
and is broadcasting the whole encounter
worldwide the doctor's assistant starts
to panic now that the japanese
government's secret is being revealed to
the world however the doctor seems calm
and says that he will sell all the
bugs's data to other governments of the
world that are willing to buy them the
assistant points her gun at the doctor
as she turns out to be a spy for the
japanese government but the doctor is
already ready for the attack dodging the
bullet with a protective barrier he then
kills the assistant with a poison that
was inserted in the lab in the case of
an emergency back in the spaceship
ichiro vows to expose everyone involved
on the mission when asked what he wants
to do when he gets back to earth kamachi
replies that he will make tombs in the
memory of everyone who died and then
come back to mars again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching